At long last, we're ready to
split our data into a training
and testing set, and to
actually build a model.
So we'll start by loading
the ca tools package,
so that we can split our data.
So we'll do library(caTools).
And then, as usual, we're going
to set our random seeds so
that everybody has
the same results.
So use set.seed and we'll
pick the number 144.
Again, the number isn't
particularly important.
The important thing is that
we all use the same one.
So as usual, we're going to
obtain the split variable.
We'll call it spl,
using the sample.split.
The outcome variable
that we pass is
labeledTerms$responsive.
And we'll do a 70/30 split.
So we'll pass 0.7 here.
So then train, the
training data frame,
can be obtained using subset
on the labeled terms where
spl is true.
And test is the subset
when spl is false.
So now we're ready
to build the model.
And we'll build a
simple cart model
using the default parameters.
But a random forest would
be another good choice
from our toolset.
So we'll start by loading up
the packages for the cart model.
We'll do library(rpart).
And we'll also load up
the rpart.plot package, so
that we can plot the outcome.
So we'll create a model
called email cart,
using the r part function.
We're predicting responsive.
And we're predicting
it using all
of the additional variables.
All the frequencies of the
terms that are included.
Obviously tilde period
is important here,
because there are 788 terms.
Way too many to
actually type out.
The data that we're
using to train the model
is just our training
dataframe, train.
And then the method
is class, since we
have a classification
problem here.
And once we've trained
the cart model,
we can plot it out using prp.
There we go.
So we can see at the very
top is the word California.
If California appears at
least twice in an email,
we're going to take the right
part over here and predict
that a document is responsive.
It's somewhat unsurprising
that California shows up,
because we know that Enron
had a heavy involvement
in the California
energy markets.
So further down the tree, we
see a number of other terms
that we could plausibly
expect to be related
to energy bids and
energy scheduling,
like system, demand,
bid, and gas.
Down here at the bottom
is Jeff, which is perhaps
a reference to Enron's CEO,
Jeff Skillings, who ended up
actually being jailed
for his involvement
in the fraud at the company.